what are the first few things that
someone needs to do before they
crowdfund
good question i guess investigation the
market first like
look around what's going on what
projects are being successful what's
happening why they are successful what
other people Eastern look around and see
there's any project that is similar to
yours and what's the best way to you
know when we started with the cosmetic
set with to all these projects that
inspire us and we to what was best out
of each one and put it together and try
to build our own model instead of just
fitting in what was and what existed at
the time so I think that's important to
you know research a little bit and then
I think it's important to be prepared to
be very very honest I think that's one
of the things that were better in our
projects like don't oversell so what you
have and try to make what you have
really good but you need to be sure that
what you're doing really good and be
honest work with what we are doing with
transparent I mean don't hide anything
just tell the you know when when our
Investor our corporate lease russian
company should drop out we could have
just said nothing because we were at
risk that 5,000 people that had given us
money would you know freak out to know
that suddenly we have 130,000 years less
and that the film was at risk but
instead of just you know say nothing we
were very public I'm safe guys we are on
the same team help us up I worked and
every time something like that happened
to us like you know some things that
went wrong or or some things that we
knew that people weren't maybe some
people where I'm going to like we were
like you know this is how it is is how
we think and it's the way closed and I
think that's one of those important
things to be prepared to be honest
I don't know if there's anything else I
can advise he preferred to how much
should someone have invested in social
media before and that goes back to our
question sort of which comes first the
chicken or the egg and how do you stay
honest it seems like it's almost hard in
some ways to
to build a campaign if you know that
you're going to the r-system it seems
like it's almost difficult to build a
social media network a little bit before
campaign
it's it's difficult night I don't think
it's something you can pay for I mean
you can pay for a campaign over social
media whatever analyst or company and
they can they can help you but you know
at some point for example if again every
time a client comes to us and says you
know what we're going to do this social
media and I want a CO and I want you
know all these tricks they use to get
traffic to the side we say you know what
we are not I mean we are not for you go
to somebody else because that's not
natural that means no you of course you
can be all numbers but they're just
numbers that's what we've been you know
fighting with brands for the last three
years because all this is you only have
five thousand uses despite the 5,000
fans okay okay just take any page that
has 50,000 funds that were probably you
know Stacy's kind of easy to get numbers
so take that put the boss and let's see
how many comments does it have and
usually have you know 50 people comment
in 50 lights and we have 5,000 and you
know it when we say something cool we
have 200 comments and 500 lights so it's
like that's our numbers so again it's
not about the amount is about the
quality so you need to start from the
ground and start you know be like very
little at the beginning and I'm trying
to connect with people and trying to
grow grow bigger but you need time for
that that's you know the worst thing of
this is like it took us three years to
build a community and it's not even
really big so you need to be prepared to
have time to be that you can do that in
30 days unless you are lucky you know
this happen to us it's like we launched
the project and then
a week after one of the biggest blocks
in Spain talk about us because they like
the project and that was you suddenly a
thousand people were coming to our side
and all of them were talking about us
because they love the project and you
know that it spread but you need to find
something or be lucky enough to have
like a gifts are something that you know
makes it big I'm from there well it
depends on how will you earn from making
a bigger place difficult stable demand
something I mean as I said you can't do
something viral it happens you can
prepare for it you can do it you know of
something that might be but again try a
hundred different things and some of
them might go viral and give you the
first pizza
you